la logique a été respectée sur le
terrain de Laas Montini volleyball dès
le premier set le derby de régional une
tient toutes ses promesses les joueurs
en blanc arrach la Manche 2624 sur cette
ultime contre dans le second acte les
joueurs d'abdatif nich pay peut-être
leurs efforts face à des plaisiris plus
efficac et plus précis sur leur phase
offensive la Montini s'accroche au score
jusqu'à 14 partout le moment choisi par
le leader du championnat pour faire la
différence et jug le
251 au fil des points les joueurs de
plaisirvillepreux marquent leur rpris
sur la rencontre ils gagnent la 3è
manche 252 dans le 4e et dernier set
scénario identique malgré une
défenseimontaine de tous les instants
les Plaisirois prennent vite le large
pour mener 18 et conclure ce match sur
un dernier service gagnant on a un
problème de régularité plaisir ça a été
constamment régulier donc ils ont pu
palier en fait échanger les passeurs au
bon moment c'est ça qui a fait surtout
leur force aujourd'hui un peu de
réussite un peu de réussite et puis
surtout beaucoup de bloc en fait
beaucoup de beaucoup de contre donc ça
aujourd'hui ça a pas beaucoup marché
surtout au centre ça a pas beaucoup
fonctionné